what I want to do in this video is start
with some point that's not on the plane
or maybe not necessarily on the plane so
let me draw let me draw a point right
over here and let's say the coordinates
of that point are X naught X sub 0 Y sub
0 and Z sub 0 or it could be specified
as a position vector I could draw the
position vector like this so the
position vector let me draw a better
dotted lines the position vector for
this could be X naught I plus y naught J
plus Z naught K it specifies this
coordinate right over here
what I want to do is find the distance
between this point and the plane
obviously there could be a lot of
distance I could find the distance
between this point and that point and
this point and this point at this point
at this point now when I say I want to
find the distance I want to find the
minimum distance and you're actually
going to get the minimum distance when
you go when you go the the perpendicular
distance to the plane or the normal
distance to the plane and we'll
hopefully see that visually as we try to
figure out how to calculate the distance
so the first thing we can do is let's
just construct a vector between this
point that's off the plane and some
point that's on the plane and we already
have a point from the last video that's
on the plane this X sub P Y sub P Z sub
P so let's construct a vector here let's
construct let's construct this orange
vector that starts on the plane its tail
is on the plane and it goes off the
plane I'm going to do that in orange it
goes off the plane to this vector that's
to this to this position X naught Y
naught Z naught so what would be what
would be how could we specify this
vector right over here well that vector
let me call that vector well I'll just
call that vector what letters have I not
used yet let me call that vector F
vector F vector F is just going to be
this yellow position vector minus this
Green position vector so it's going to
be this each of these chord this X
component is going to be the difference
of the x coordinates its y-coordinates
squared be the difference of the y
coordinate is going to be X naught X
naught minus X sub P I subtracted the
x-coordinates i plus y naught mine
YP j+ go to the next line plus Z naught
minus Z P minus Z P K so fair enough
that's just some vector that comes off
of the plane and on to this point but
what we want to find out what we want to
find out is this distance we want to
find out this distance in yellow the
distance that if I were to take a normal
off of the plane and go straight to the
point that's going to be the shortest
distance and actually you can see it
visually now because if you look at we
can actually form a right triangle here
so this this base of the right triangle
is along the plane this side is normal
to the plane so this is a right angle
and you can see if I take any point any
other point on the plane it will form a
hypotenuse to on on a right triangle and
obviously the shortest side here or the
shortest way to get to the plane is
going to be this distance right here as
opposed to the hypotenuse this side will
always be shorter than that side so
given that we know this vector here how
can we figure out how can we figure out
this length here how can we figure out
this length here in blue well we could
figure out the magnitude of this vector
so we could this the length of this side
right here is going to be the magnitude
of the vector so it's going to be the
magnitude of the vector F that will just
give us this length but we want this
blue length well we could think about it
if this was some angle and on the
writing ceiling small if this was some
angle theta we could use some pretty
straight up pretty some pretty
straightforward trigonometry if the
distance under question is D you could
say cosine of theta we could say that
cosine of theta is equal to the adjacent
side over the hypotenuse or is equal to
D D is the adjacent side is equal to D
over the hypotenuse well the hypotenuse
is the magnitude of this vector it's the
magnitude of the vector F or we could
say the magnitude of the vector F times
the cosine of theta I'm just multiplying
both sides times the magnitude of the
vector X F is equal to is equal to D but
that's still you might say okay well Sal
we know what Z
is we could we could are sorry we know
what f is we can figure that out we
could figure out its magnitude but what
we don't know what theta is how do we
figure out what theta and to do that
let's just think about it a little bit
this angle this angle theta is the same
angle so we don't know this distance
here isn't necessarily the same as the
length of the normal vector but it's
definitely going in the same direction
so this angle here is really the same
thing as the angle between this vector
and the normal vector and so you might
remember from earlier linear algebra
when we talk about the dot products of
two vectors it involves something with
the cosine of the angle between them and
to make that fresh in your mind let's
divide let's multiply and divide both
sides let me multiply and divide the
left side of this equation by the
magnitude of the normal vector so I'm
obviously not changing its value I'm
multiplying and dividing by the same
number so I'm going to multiply by the
magnitude of the normal vector and I'm
going to divide divide by the magnitude
of the normal vector so I mean I'm I'm
just essentially multiplying by one so I
have not changed this but when you do it
in this it might ring a bell this
expression up here this expression right
here is the dot product of the normal
vector of the normal vector and this
vector right here F so this right here
is the dot product this is n this is n
dot F up there it's equal to the product
of their magnitudes times the cosine of
the angle between them so the distance
that shortest distance we care about is
a dot product between this vector the
normal vector divided by the magnitude
divided by the magnitude of the normal
divided by the norm magnitude of the
normal vector so let's do that let's
take the dot product between the normal
and this and we already figured out in
the last video the normal vector if you
have the equation of a plane the normal
vector is literally its components are
just the coefficients on the x y&z term
so this is a normal vector right over
here so let's take let's literally take
the dot product so n n dot F is going to
be equal to
to a times X not minus XP so it's going
to be equal to I'll do that in pink
so it'll be a X not minus a XP and then
plus B times the y component here so
plus B why not I'm just distributing the
B minus B Y P and then plus do another
color here and this C is too close of a
color plus C times this come Z component
so plus C Z naught minus C minus C Z P
and all of that over the magnitude of
the normal vector so what's the
magnitude of the normal vector going to
be it's just the square root of the
normal vector dotted with itself so it's
just
each of these guys squared added to
themselves and you're taking the square
root so it's the square root the square
root we I can do a nicer looking radical
sign than that it's the square root of a
squared plus B squared plus plus C
squared now what does this up here
simplify to let me just rewrite this so
this is this is the distance in question
this right here is equal to the distance
but let's see if we can simplify it so
first we can take all of the terms with
the X naught these are involved the
point that sits off the plane remember X
not Y not Z not set off the plane so
this is a X naught plus B Y naught plus
C Z naught and then what are these terms
equal to what are these terms over a X P
a X negative a XP minus B YP minus C Z P
well if you remember here D in the
equation of a in the equation of a plane
D when we started in the last video when
we tried to figure out what the normal
to a plane is D is if we this this point
XP sits on the plane D is a XP plus B y
plea plus B YP plus zc zp or another way
you could say it is
negative D negative D would be negative
a and it's just the difference between
lowercase and uppercase here right we
say that lowercase a is the same as this
uppercase a so it's negative a XP minus
B YP minus c zp I'm just using what we
got from the last video this is what D
is so negative D will be this business
and that's exactly what we have over
here of negative a XP negative B yp- C Z
P so all of this term this term and this
term simplifies to a minus D and
remember this negative capital B this is
the D from the equation of the plane not
the D not the distance D so this is the
numerator of our distance and so and
then the denominator or distance is just
the square root of a squared plus B
squared plus C squared and we're done
this tells us the distance between any
point and a plane this is a pretty
intuitive formula here because all we're
doing if we have some if I'm given you
if I give you let me give you a give you
an example let's say I have the plane if
I have the plane 1 X minus 2y plus 3z is
equal to 5 so that's some plane and let
me pick some point that's not on the
plane so let's say I have the point
let's say I have the point I don't know
let me say have the point 2 2 3 and let
me make sure it's not on the plane so
it's 2 minus 6 is negative negative yes
this one let me just pick a random one
so this definitely is not on the plane
because we have 2 minus 6 plus 3 that
gives us negative 1 which is not 5 so
this is definitely not on the plane we
can find the distance between this point
and the plane using the formula we just
derived we literally just evaluate it at
so this will just be 1 times 1 times 2 1
times muses that same color one times 2
minus minus 2 times I'm going to fill it
in plus 3
Plus 3 times something minus 5 all of
that over and I haven't put these guys
in let me do that right now so 1 times 2
minus 2 times 3 plus 3 times 1 this one
minus 5 and kind of bring it over to the
left-hand side all of that over all of
that over the square root of 1 squared
which is 1 plus negative 2 squared which
is 4 plus 3 squared which is 9 so it's
going to be equal to let's see this is 2
minus 6 or negative 6 and then you have
plus 3 and then minus 5 so this is what
this is 5 2 plus 3 is 5 minus 5 so those
cancel out so this is negative 6 so it's
equal to negative 6 over the square root
of 5 plus 9 is 14 over the square root
of 14 and you're done
so hopefully you find that useful and
hopefully we can apply this in other
example problems